who doesn't like birthday cake and
what i'm gonna show you today is that
there are good ways and there are bad
ways of cutting a cake and the classic
way
the bad way
is like this which would be normal you
put the knife in the center one bit of
the slice
a bit of a slice
that's like the classic it is the
classic isn't it it's almost like a pie
chart you know one thing about the word
pie chart in france they call them camom
bear which is like a cheese it's
actually like a cheese chart in france
interesting cultural differences in math
speak so this is what you would do you
take this
you would put this over here you eat it
and then you leave this in the fridge
overnight and the reason why this is a
really bad way of cutting a cake is that
these bits here
are just going to get dry
and so when you come the following day
to have your cake
you know you do another one you know
another slice like this
this side here lovely and soft this will
be dry and horrible you're not
maximizing the amount of gastronomic
pleasure that you can make from this
cake there is a better way a way that is
more than 100 years old and was
discovered or invented by
one of britain's most famous and
brilliant
mathematical scientists this is
a copy of nature the
famous
science magazine from december the 20th
and
in the letters to the editor here it
says the headline cutting a round cake
on scientific principles the ordinary
method of cutting out a wedge he writes
is
very faulty what he suggests is and he
gives an illustration for it the proper
way the scientific way the
mathematically perfect way of cutting a
round cake and it is as follows so
we have
another cake
the first slice
will be
like this
it's breaking all the rules
of a cake etiquette
perfect okay so this is the first one
and then i need to
find a way of
taking it out
okay we can stick that there and that
has got to be the price the prime steak
of that cake isn't it
it's the t-bone cut here what we need to
do
we need to close the cake together
like this
and that's going to come apart so look
what i've got here
i have got some rubber bands
to make sure
that stays together the following day
all the flesh the sponge is going to be
nice and soft so how do we do the second
slice the second slice i guess it's not
your birthday anymore so you're not
going to have one that's
quite as big be interesting to work out
the actual proportions
this is
and you get a lovely
breaking with elastic bands too which is
exciting
this is
slice two or it actually is slice two
which
has two
slices two parts good
so we put this back together and we can
keep on going obviously i'm going to
want to use the elastic band
to put the cake
yeah that is perfect that is gonna stay
so fresh for day three
day three how should we do day three
again let's um turn it around
i think this is going to be the slice
for day three
again the satisfying snap of the elastic
bands
and
i don't know if you've thought about it
before but
this triangular slices are really
annoying anyway because
it's not very satisfying having a nice
uniform slice like that is a lot better
so here we go again
this is
at the end of day three there's four and
this is going to be perfect and
gradually we are
slicing it keep on going
i think for
the um
mathematical loaners
who don't want to share their cakes this
is it could be useful for a bit more of
this interview including more about the
guy that came up with this cake cutting
method have a look at the extra footage
over on numberphile2 and if you just
like to hear more great stories from
alex he's got a new book out just
recently alex through the looking glass
how life reflects numbers and numbers
reflect life it's really good it's also
just out in the us but it has a
different name in the u.s
it's called the grapes of math
i'll put links to it in the video
description